(audience clapping)
- I...
- I know.
I'm excited too. I'm so
excited. Wait, okay. So wait.
I'm gonna first start with
the holidays are here.
You look beautiful in red, by the way.
This is a color for you.
- Thank you very much.
I'm really trying to ground
myself 'cause I'm looking into
your eyes and this is so cool.
- Oh my God. Same.
- Oh my God.
- And I literally, and I was so excited.
'cause last night I was like reading up.
I always do like my homework before
because I know things
about like your work,
but never the personal thing.
- You know about my work?
- I love your work.
- Oh my gosh, I voted for
you on 'American Idol.'
- Oh my God. Well, I have
seen everything you're in.
- I saw 'From Justin to
Kelly' the day it came out.
- Oh my God. That's a real fan. Okay?
This is not good.
We're gonna get into that
acting versus singing.
But before we get there, like
for the holidays, do you get into this?
- I really do.
- I know, I was reading up on you,
I feel like we're so similar.
I love giving gifts.
- I love giving gifts.
- Like thoughtful.
- Mm-hmm.
- Me too.
- I've already started. I'm
like a month in already.
- I usually start in October.
- Yeah.
- Yeah?
- Yeah, because I feel
like it starts to come,
you start to see things and you go,
"oh, I should get that for this person."
And why wait?
- And if you wait, all of a sudden
everything hits you and you have no time.
- Exactly. And I also like to wrap
my presents really well.
- Me too! Me too.
- I make all the tags. It's
a whole thing. It takes time.
- People offer to do it and I'm offended.
- No.
- I'm like, "No, you're
gonna run it." Yeah.
- No
- Yeah.
I do the like bits and bobbles,
I do tags, I do everything.
- I have a theme every year.
It's a thing. It's a thing.
- Yeah.
This year I think I'm going
with just solid parchment,
like classic.
- With twine?
- Yes, yes.
- Yes I've done that.
- Yes.
- Brown paper package.
- But then splashes of color...
- Yep.
- Yes.
- No, I did that a couple years ago.
- Favorite things
- It was great.
- I love you so much.
We should be friends.
- Yes. Okay, let's do it.
- So I also heard you did something random
like I would do as well
and have done in different countries.
When I go to country,
I'm really inspired by the surroundings.
And you went and you were in the
presence of people looming right?
In France, is that..?
- Oh yeah. Yeah.
- Yes. And then you
ended up buying a loom?
- Yes, I've decided I'm
a textile artist now.
- Yes. But it's kind of
fun to try new things.
- Oh, it's the best,
I mean, it's the spice of life, really.
- Yes. I saw a quilt that I loved in some
antique thing, and I was
like, "I could do this."
I don't do it well, but I do it.
- It doesn't matter.
That's not the point.
- I get so much joy out of it.
- Yes.
- So what are the things have you tried?
- Oh my gosh.
I've tried so many things.
I mean, this started when I was a kid.
I was like all kinds of dance
lessons and drawing lessons.
- Me too.
- And tennis and... Oh gosh. Everything.
Ice skating, figure skating
was my thing for a while.
- Figure skating?
- Yeah. And then like,
now as time's gone on,
it's like I'm rock climbing
or I'm doing Judo or now I'm
like, "I'm a textile artist."
And everyone's like, "Okay,
let's give this six months."
- See, I don't have a friendly...
all my friends are different from me.
Not one is kind of crazy
and likes everything like you do too.
- I don't have that at all.
- I don't have that friend. Me too.
- Yeah.
- Why not? Even if you suck
at it, it's fun just to try.
You get one life.
- It's fun to know and there was a year,
this ended up being exhausting.
So I tried this out.
Don't do it.
Where I wouldn't order anything at a
restaurant that I hadn't made myself.
- What?
- I thought it would be fun. It's not.
- What do you mean? I don't understand.
- It's like I couldn't order
lasagna at a restaurant
until I learned how to make lasagna.
- Oh.
- So I would do everything.
- I would starve.
- It forced me to try.
- Yeah. I don't cook well.
This is the one thing
I've learned about you
that we are... Yeah.
- I'm gonna show you how to do that.
- Here's the thing.
I can cook.
- You can do a fried egg. Come on.
- I can, I don't like it.
I can make breakfast, I can
make lunch, I can do dinner.
I can do it. I hate it.
- Why?
- Unless people are in
the kitchen with me,
I'm just in there by myself.
And then my kids hate it
anyway, whatever I make.
And I'm just like...
- Yeah. That's why I like it.
- It's exhausting.
- I love it. I could be
in the kitchen all day.
- No, I'm supporting the
economy via Postmates.
- That's great. Every restaurant,
these people need money,
so I'm helping them.
- Yeah. It's very helpful.
Everybody's doing their job.
- Exactly and then everybody
can get what you want.
Like, I just gave up. I
used to be that person
that felt like I was a failure as a mom
unless I was cooking it.
But they don't fricking eat it.
(Brie laughs)
So I'm like, I'm exhausted after work.
And I'm like, "You're gonna
eat the pasta." And they don't.
- So Postmates it is.
- I know.
I really wish I did. I like baking though.
But baking is fun.
- Oh yeah. Yeah. Baking is great.
- Because it's chemistry.
It's... well, we're gonna get there.
I didn't even mean to do that.
- Nice segue, Kelly.
- But I didn't even mean to do it.
No, but it's because I like it precise.
- Yeah. That's part of why
baking is not totally my thing.
Because you really have
to follow directions.
And I'm not good at that.
- Oh my God, I need you
to tell me what to do.
- I'm not like a rules girly.
I'm like a let's just throw
things together and make it happen.
- Yeah. I do that when cooking
and then it's not edible.
- That's the thing.
- I think that we love this though.
You love hot dogs. And I love hot dogs.
- I do love hot dogs.
I do. Yeah.
- When did this start? This passion?
- Oh gosh. Yeah.
When did my love affair
with the hot dog begin?
I've always loved hot dogs.
But my best friend, Courtney McBroom,
who's also the food consultant on...
Oh yeah, you can see it right there.
[Kelly]- In Lessons in Chemistry.
[Brie]- Yeah. Food Consultant
on Lessons in chemistry.
She started, she's the president
of the Hot Dog Appreciation Club.
And I'm a proud member, obviously.
- Nice. Nice.
- And so this is segued into a
hot dog appreciation festival
that's once a year at my family's house.
My stepdad dresses as a hot dog.
It's a lot, but it's a
really great, it's super fun.
Oh yeah. You can see it all going down.
- So I hear you have a debate...
with that fanny pack. Get it.
I hear there's a debate. Yeah.
- Okay. Let's get into
the heart of the issues.
- If a hot dog is a sandwich
or if it's separate.
If it's a hot dog, it's not...
- I think a hot dog is a hot dog.
I think to say that it is
a sandwich is blasphemy.
But Courtney thinks that it's a sandwich.
And it's very hard to argue with someone
who is the president of the
Hot Dog Appreciation Club.
It's like, "Why am I fighting
reality?" I don't know.
It's kind of fun.
- You know what's funny is
I've never thought about it.
maybe y'all have, but I've
never thought about it.
But it is bread with meat in between.
- I know, but it's connected
and that makes all the difference.
(audience claps)
- Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay.
But what about a Subway sandwich?
A Sub is connected.
Am I blowing your mind right now?
- It's not connected. It's not connected.
It's not connected!
- No, you're totally right.
Now I wanna see, show of hands,
how many people? I won't be offended.
I'm just curious. How many people
think a hot dog is a sandwich?
[Audience Member]- No.
[Kelly]- We are alone!
[Brie] See, the people
who say no are empathic
that it's a no.
And we don't even really know
why. But it's just wrong.
But I'm very proud of the five people
that stood strong in their beliefs.
- Yes, thank you.
You stood with me. We
were alone on an island,
but it's okay.
I never thought about it before.
And then I was like, well, it kind
of is, like a Sub sandwich.
- It's thought provoking.
- Yeah.
- It's thought provoking for sure.
- Thought provoking?
You can see right now
in Lessons in Chemistry
on Apple TV Plus
and in The Marvels, which
is in theaters right now.
I love all the things you do.
- Thank you.
- What I found crazy though
is that you're singing
and dancing in the new Marvels.
- Yeah, we can talk
about that now. Finally.
- I know! Like were
you excited about that?
- I was thrilled.
the whole time when I first
read the script, I was like,
"They're not gonna let
me actually do this."
But they did. They did.
And it was a lot of work.
We had to rehearse for like a month.
James Murphy of LCD Sound
System did the music.
And it was incredible.
Absolutely incredible.
- So it's like, 'cause
it's one of the places
that you go and they all sing.
- Yes. Yes. It's a planet where
their language is in song.
They can't hear anything
unless it's in song.
- This is my planet.
- Yeah, it's really fun.
- Yes, we love this planet.
You actually released an album as a teen,
which I did not know, I found out.
- That's probably for the best.
- Well, you saw From Justin to Kelly
So that's probably not the best.
But we all have our things.
But no, but what, what
kind of style was it?
- I mean, it was pop.
I played guitar, I wrote the songs.
- You like writing though.
- I do.
[Kelly] - You enjoy
writing, you still write?
[Brie] -Yeah, I do. Yeah.
[Kelly] - Look at you!
- Wowzers. Yeah.
- Finally out of P.E.
- See, and these are reasons why
15 year olds shouldn't have albums.
[Kelly] - Or, why they should.
- Or maybe they should.
- I even look back at my stuff
and I'm like, I always say
I should make an album like
better with age and like recut things.
'cause you're just babies.
- I love that.
- And your voice isn't like grown.
You know, you don't
know what you're doing.
- Yeah, no. I didn't
know what I was doing.
- I definitely didn't.
- I can say that. I
mean, it was really fun.
It was just a strange thing that happened.
I still can't believe that that happened.
- A lot of actors sing though. Like a lot
of actors would come on the show.
I didn't really know that
before doing this show.
But a lot of people are like
in bands or were in bands.
- Yeah, they work well together.
- "I don't do it anymore."
And I'm like, "Whatever."
I think it's awesome to
be creative like that.
- Totally.
- You should sing with
me one time on the show.
- Yes please!
- Well, okay!
Well let's talk about
Lessons in Chemistry.
Speaking of that,
my recent album was called 'Chemistry'
and I was in a bookstore
buying for books for my kids.
And I was on my way out and it
was like sitting right there
and it said, 'Lessons in Chemistry.'
This was like a while
back and I was like, well,
this is a sign I should buy this book.
So I started reading it
and then now it's like a
show. So I'm so excited.
- Yes. That's the show now.
- Have you read the book before?
- Yeah. I got the book about two years
before it was released.
So it's been like my
little secret for a while.
And now it's been just amazing
to see it out in the
world and doing so well.
[Kelly] - Yeah. It's just such a cool idea
and how back in the day, how women had
to kind of pivot and navigate.
- Yes. It deals with that quite a bit.
- Relevance would be a good word.
Are you a foodie like you are in the show?
- Oh yes, definitely. I mean,
I spend most of my time,
if I'm not on set, I'm cooking.
That's just what I do. I'm very
comfortable in the kitchen.
- I really wanna be your friend.
'cause then I'll just eat it.
- Yeah, you can.
- Explain the show and
the book to everybody
that doesn't know.
- Sure, the book
and the show is based
around this character, Elizabeth Zott.
And she is a chemist who is not able
to do her passions because,
you know, sexism is a thing.
And so she ends up needing
to do a quick detour from
the thing that she loves
and gets a job as a TV show
host for a cooking show.
And she fuses her love of
science and chemistry with food
and becomes this big sensation
because she talks to
housewives as if they are
smart, capable individuals.
And so it kind of just is
tracking her and her life.
It's a really, really beautiful story.
- Incredibly powerful.
- It says a lot about
life, the journey of life,
how it's unexpected and hard
and beautiful all at the same time.
- I just like that it's unexpected
I never would've thought
I would did on this job,
but I love that it's unexpected
and you still can kind of incorporate
things that you love into it.
And I think that people should be
open-minded about that.
- Oh yes.
- Because sometimes we
get stuck in our things
and you seem like a person that,
like once you finish an
acting job, you're like,
"Maybe I should skydive."
- Oh yeah, definitely.
- It's just like, I don't know
if I'll ever do that again.
- That's what I'm saying.
You're like, "Wait, I've done this."
So I like to keep changing it up too.
- I think that's the thing is like,
then I find...
- Monotony kills me.
- Yeah. I have to change it up.
And then I always end up
finding a way back to acting.
But like for right now,
I've taken pretty much a
year off and all I've done is dance.
I've been doing like six
hours a day of dance.
- What kind?
- A lot of ballet. But other things too.
I've been doing tap now.
- Did you relate it all to the character?
- Oh yes, very much so. Yes.
[Kelly] -Definitely the food part.
- I mean, of course there's
always things that I'm like,
oh, I have to understand that better.
Like, I just am not innately
as smart in science and
chemistry as she is.
I had to learn about that.
But in terms of like a
woman with a passion, trying
to make her way through like, of course.
And also the way that,
you know, we try our best
to quantify life and set
ourselves up for success,
but there's just things
that are unexpected,
things that happen.
And I've of course had times in my life
where I've been like, "I don't understand
why this is happening."
And then in time it reveals itself why.
And that life somehow organizes itself
in a really spectacular way.
- Yeah. Wow. You should write
a book. You're good at this.
- Oh, maybe I'll do that next.
- I was like, "You should write a book."
You've never done that, right? Try that.
You have a very great
way of putting things
that are very relatable.
- Oh, thank you.
- But elevated. It's nice.
Okay, so were you good
in science at school?
- I mean, yeah, I'm competitive
so I wanna be good at everything,
but I'm not like...
- I'm competitive and
I'm not good in science.
- I was always way more
interested in the arts.
Like any class that was like,
"We're gonna do a project."
I would like hone in on
that and they'd be like,
"Okay, we just wanted
like a tiny little thing.
You've made a diorama
and you didn't do the rest of your work."
And like, what's going on?
It's just very clear
on what I wanted to do.
- Yes. Are you ready for a game then?
- Yeah, yeah!
- Cool, because we're
both competitive. Okay.
- Okay, let's do it.
- All right. Lessons in
Chemistry is on Apple TV+,
you've got to check it out everybody.
And The Marvels is in theaters now,
which is also equally incredible.